[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so without further ado I present to you
one Chi Saito thank you I had to ask you
yeah you told us about something really
special about your your socks yeah so
I'm actually wearing brand new ones I
got those ones from the lorry yesterday
these are new and PM socks I had an old
pair of NPM socks and they're like
getting a little old so thank you for
another like quick clarifying thing I
actually I'm mostly like deaf punks
newest album but when I say that I like
it I mean like I listened to it two
times yesterday while I was working on
my slides so I really really like it and
thank you all for coming today
and I it means a lot for me that you're
here because my fellow web developers I
am angry and I am angry because for
years us JavaScript errs have been told
to never ever ever ever use switch
statements and you know I mean there's
there's reasons all over for it and
today I'd like to talk about some of
those particularly I'd like to to recap
a bit of that that awful tragedy tragedy
and then talk about the the brave web
developers who've come before us and the
ways that they've come up with skirting
around switch statements and then I'd
like to introduce you to a tc39 proposal
for a new incarnation of switch
statements that would leverage pattern
matching inside of JavaScript so with
all that being said my name is Juan
cocido I am a Canadian
colombian-american developer and I am
working for a company called testable
which is a consulting company where we
go to other people's teams and we help
them write nice code and we try to be
nice about writing code we try to help
people be nice to each other about
writing code I really like playing
guitar and speaking foreign languages
and traveling so if those are all things
that urine to come chat with me about it
sometime here is a picture of me then
here's a picture of me as a child here's
a picture of me with bleached blonde
hair and here is a picture of me that my
co-workers drew at our company retreat
last week I'm not sure why so I'm
wearing at Columbia soccer jersey I also
have my guitar but I'm Abraham Lincoln
which which makes sense right we're both
seven feet tall
we're very similar people all in all and
so let's get back to switch statements
so what is wrong with switch statements
why shouldn't we use them well if you
believe Google there's approximately 903
million reasons why we shouldn't reuse
them my personal favorite of them is
that switch statements are evil so I'd
honestly I'd heard this when I started
programming that we should avoid switch
statements in JavaScript and I didn't
have a lot of reasons why until I
started researching for this talk and
really putting this together and
morality of switch statements aside the
main reasons I could find were two the
first revolve so here's just a basic
switch statement it's a function that
takes in a number and then it switches
over that number and just has three
cases for the possible values of it each
one logs out the word of that number
you've passed in if none of them match
we hit a default statement so the main
reason domain of two reasons I could
find for where people say not to use
switch statements one is about their
syntax so in JavaScript almost all types
of control flow we do has braces curly
braces for matching them case is one of
the very few things that users colons
and because of that people get really
upset so not good in case you're ever
designing a language avoid colons the
other one that I could find is one that
I find a lot more of an actual complaint
which is that case statements have kind
of tricky semantics so in the side of a
case after you've matched you have to be
sure to explicitly
break out of that case
so for example in this example if you
say you have the number 1 we're gonna
hit the console dot log for 1 and then
we're gonna break out of it so that's
good however if we don't do that and we
do the 2 or the 3 so what's gonna happen
here is that when we enter the case
statement for the two we're gonna log
out 2 however then executions gonna
continue and it's also gonna log out the
value for 3 and the value for default
because since none of those have told
JavaScript exit out of the switch
statement it's is gonna match all those
cases even though the number isn't 3 and
it's already been matched so this is
something that I think definitely could
lead to some unexpected bugs and is is
worth avoiding switch at least to avoid
these type of headaches so how do people
manage to avoid switch statements what
else do we use so I found two main
techniques the first is to use nested
ternary statements so ternary statements
are if-else there this question mark
colon operator so what that does is that
at first evaluates the condition on the
left so we would evaluate whether the
number is equal to one and then if that
evaluates to true we execute the second
statement however if it evaluates to
false then we would evaluate the
statement after the colon so what this
technique does is it just does a chain
of them so that if the first condition
doesn't match then you evaluate the
second dition if that doesn't match you
evaluate the third condition and it
works and my main issue with it is that
I think that it looks ok when you put it
like this but it's relying on some code
style that isn't very normal in
JavaScript and JavaScript this just
isn't how we would indent things so I
took this function and I ran it through
prettier which I think for most of us is
kind of like the industry standard on
how to format code nowadays and it comes
out of something more like this and here
you can really see that like it's not as
straightforward of a statement as we
were looking at it before this also to
me highlights one other thing that I'm
no performance expert but I have the
feeling that this is
very performant code because to hit the
default statement you would actually end
up going through and have one by one
evaluating all of the statements above
it so this type of deep nesting is not
something that won me over so the next
approach that I found is one that I'm
more of a fan of so this is to use an
object literal which is very common in
JavaScript and idiomatic and use that to
control all of our cases so we would
have an object here I called it the
values object and you would have a key
on that for all over the different cases
that we could match and then the value
from that is what we would want to
return so then at the bottom what we
would do is just take the type that
we've passed in and then we would pull
out a value from this object that we've
defined before and then we'll return
that if we've passed in a type that
isn't one of the cases that were set up
to handle then we're gonna get an
undefined value back from that object
which is false II so then what we can do
is go ahead and get the default value
and return that instead so this works I
have a little bit of a gripe with the
fact that we have to explicitly call a
default statement to me it seems a
little weird but maybe I'm just
nitpicking here I think a concern that
is much more valid is that any of the
cases have a false e value so false null
undefined then when you pull them out of
the object and Brun them through this or
check for the default value they would
evaluate to false so then we would
return the default and you're all
probably smarter than me but I would hit
a bug here for sure so I'm not not a
hundred percent on this approach ya
value false e not good so then we would
hit this default statement so then let's
look at another example so this is where
I think switch statements are most used
in JavaScript today which is inside of
Redux reducers so inside of this simple
example sorry to back up if any of you
haven't used redux in redux a common
pattern like how Redux reducers work is
that it's a function that take
State and it takes some instructions
about how to update that state and then
the function is in charge of calculating
all of the pauses like the updates to
that state and returning back a new
state so here we have a counter you know
the counter would be a number and then
we can either increment that decrement
that or reset it so what we would do is
that in redux you have an action and an
action has a type which tells you how to
go through this update statement so if
that type is increment we would push up
our state if it's d comment will push it
down if it's reset we would return 0 and
then if for some reason it's not any of
those predetermined ones we want to just
keep the state the way it is so there's
a there's a tricky thing here which well
so let's take the switch statement and
first let's switch it over to this
object approach that we were discussing
before so if we were to do that what we
would do is cut out that switch
statement have an object that's all of
the different cases so it has a key for
all of the different types of actions
and then on the right hand it has the
how we want to update the state then at
the bottom we would go ahead and pull
out that case or we would return the
default so here we run into concern
which is to illustrate it a little more
let's think about what if we could
change instead of always updating or
decrementing by one what if we can make
that an arbitrary amount so now the
amount that we're gonna increment or
decrement by is also going to flow in
with this action so here at the very top
we have just a little bit of
destructuring if it's not something
you're familiar with we'll talk about it
a little later so we're gonna reach into
that action and we're gonna pull out the
type of the action we're also going to
pull out the data of the action and as
we do that we'll rename it to the amount
then inside of our case is what we want
to do is increment state by the amount
and decrement state by amount so here we
run into a bug and the bug is that if
we're in the case of reset all we want
to do is reset the state to zero so
we're not incrementing or decrementing
by any amount so it would make perfect
sense for amount to be undefined how
as soon as we hit this skate statement
definition as soon as we call this
function we're eagerly gonna evaluate
what state plus amount means and that
means that we're either gonna get state
plus undefined state plus null state -
no this is bad i I didn't run this to be
sure but I'm pretty sure this would
result in your program just blowing up
so the way to avoid this is that instead
of just having cases the return of value
we would instead make the cases return a
function so that when you evaluate the
function at that point we do that math
and this would make sure that when you
hit the reset case it hasn't evaluated
the other two cases and it would avoid
this bug so this means that you know at
the bottom now we're gonna be having to
call will pull out our case from the
object and then we'll have to evaluate
it and we'll do that again for the
default case and this isn't I mean it's
not terrible it just seems to me like a
lot of ceremony for something that a
language could and should be able to
handle for you and a lot of languages do
so let's backtrack now and talk about a
couple other ones so here's for example
elm Elm is a language that embraces
switch statements a lot in fact so much
so that in Elm it's considered a code
smell to use an if statement or any
other type of evaluation if a case would
do so here in Elm and an action is a
data type and the data type would be one
of a bunch of different cases then when
a case could involve with it some data
attached to it so here when we're in the
increment case will automatically get
another bit of data with it which is the
amount and when we hit the reset case
reset has no amount so it just wouldn't
be a part of that data type at all in
rust there's something very similar so
we would have an action which is a
struct which has two different type in
an amount to find on it and then we
would have a function that matches over
that type and then lets you do different
stuff based on it if you actually know
any rust don't look at this too closely
because I don't and I have a
this actually doesn't compile and then
the one that we're gonna focus on the
most is elixir the reason why we're
gonna do that is because elixir has the
closest semantics out of these languages
to JavaScript so in elixir we would
define a function the function would
take a state and in action we would case
over that action and then if it matched
whether we wanted to increment decrement
or reset we would do we would take the
amount calculate a new state based off
of it and this leaves us with a question
of if all these other languages have a
way of doing robust handling of cases
why can't we have something like that in
JavaScript so at this point actually
want to take a quick intermission to
show off my water bottle for all of you
cuz I'm super proud of my water bottle
we were talking about it backstage
actually I have all of these stickers
from different conferences that I've
gone to and some of them like this one
for example is the the most famous
soccer player in Colombian history but
it's actually the MPM wombat dressed up
as him so this is fantastic and if I
were to lose this water bottle I'm
really confident that I'd never be able
to get this sticker again so if you have
a lot of stickers and don't know what to
do with them I really encourage you to
find other things that aren't your
laptop to put them on because I'm a
little too anxious to put them on my
laptop but my water bottle is now my
favourite object so with that little
intermission to kind of give you all a
breath of fresh air let's talk about
JavaScript so why can't we have this in
JavaScript because we can actually so
there's right now a proposal in front of
tc39 that's reached stage 1 for
introducing pattern matching into
JavaScript so what pattern matching
would be doing is it would be taking
semantic close to what we have for for
switch statements now but then it would
be taking all of the semantics of
destructuring and it would be filling
them into that language feature so let's
take a step back and let's talk about
what I just mentioned about
destructuring so destructuring is a
feature you can use whenever you're
defining variables with like const or
virus and what it allows you to do is
that it allows you to not just define
a simple variable by variable on the
left value on the right but to actually
do some logic as you do that so in this
simple case on the right hand side we
have an object and the object has an X
property and a Y property then when we
create a variable we can use the curly
brace object syntax on the left hand
side and what we can tell it is go ahead
and make two new variables for me x and
y and make the value of each of them
equal to the value of that property and
the object on the right this is really
cool because it's so if we were to do
this we would get like we would just
have like a easier way to pull things
out of objects we can also do other
things on top of it like we can do
default values so here what we're doing
is that when we define these variables
we can give them default values so we
can say that the default value for X if
we don't find it on the right-hand side
will be the poop emoji and the value for
Y will be the ghost emoji so the the
results of this is interesting so the
object on the right does have both of
these properties but for the first one
the value of x is undefined so to back
up if we were to ask for a variable that
isn't in that object at all let's say if
we were asked for a Z then Z pulled out
of that object would be undefined so we
would get it's a default value with X
even though the X property does exist
because its values undefined
we'll also get the default value however
this isn't the case for Y because Y has
a value of null we will actually get
that value out of the destructuring but
I'm gonna convince you that this is
actually a good thing it's not a problem
other things that you can do with the
structuring it's not just for objects
you can do it with arrays so what we can
do is we can go ahead and define x and y
to the first and second values of an
array just by applying the same array
syntax on the left this is really cool
it allows you a way of doing much easier
variable assignment it also allows you
to ignore parts of an array as you're
pulling stuff out so let's say that we
only care about the second value we
don't care about the first all we can do
is leave in the assignment will leave
the
first slot open and then have the second
slot then we're never gonna pull
anything out for that GS comp string
instead we're only gonna pull out the
second value into the Y this also allows
you to do really cool things like to
leverage rest argument or sprit sorry I
get confused of this so spread is when
your you have an arranger spreading it
apart here what we're doing is rest
arguments so let's say that we have an
array with four things in it we're gonna
take the first out of it and put it into
a variable X but then this triple dot
syntax what it's gonna do is it's gonna
take all the rest of the contents of
that array and it's gonna put them
together into the variable rest so now
we have one variable of the first and
another variable which is the entire
tail this is really cool and so having
covered all of that 4d structuring let's
talk about how this would fit into the
pattern matching proposal so here is the
update state or the update counter that
we discussed earlier with Redux handlers
and how we would do this if we had
pattern matching available so we will do
a case statement and the case statement
will switch over the type of the action
then the proposed semantics right now
have this new keyword when and with when
you would put the value that you want to
match against next to it and then an
arrow and afterwards whatever you want
to do so here would be saying that if
the type of action directly matches the
string increment then we can go ahead
and evaluate the state with +1 so this
is this is cool however that's not where
we stopped so because we can use all of
this destructuring semantics we can go
ahead and just case over the entire
action when we case over the action we
can on the right hand of then do a D
structuring so we can say that if the
action has a type property and that type
property matches the string increment
then what we want to do is pull out the
property data but rename that to amount
and now the variables that we've decided
to find inside of that destructor
are available to the other side of that
arrow so we can just go ahead and say
state plus amount which we've received
from that destructuring this is really
cool and we can do it with a raise as
well so another way to do this would be
that we could do a case statement over a
new array and the array could have the
type of the action and the data of the
action and then all we would do is we
would match against the first value
being increment and then we would just
put the second value into a variable
amount we could do that the same with
decrement and this is okay another one
that I skipped over before but when we
get to the bottom we're doing variable
assignment so any variable that we put
here will get assigned into there so the
effect of this of this when underscore
is the same effect as a default case so
what we'll do is we'll say if we get to
this point in the function and we
haven't matched any previous case
whatever we've put in the case we'll
just instead be a sign into this
variable and we'll match this instead so
this is a really cool really easy way to
do default arguments or to do default
cases other places where this could
apply could be in nodejs
so in node a really common thing is to
have air backs or error first call backs
so here we could be reading a file we
passed the first argument is the name of
the file the second is the encoding we
want to read out of and then inside of
our callback we could do a case
statement over the error that we could
possibly get back and the contents so
here the first step that we would do is
we could say if the error is explicitly
null which is idiomatically where you'll
always get back a node then we can go
ahead and match this case because we
know that the error is null and
therefore we have some data we can do
stuff with it then in the next statement
we could do is alright if the error
isn't null and we have an error let's go
ahead and pull that out and then we'll
do some error handling something went
wrong and then we could have another
statement after that saying for some
reason the error isn't no but it's also
not true T value so something went wrong
here I think that case would actually be
impossible and node unless someone it
explicitly returned false to you I guess
is the only way that it would happen but
yeah it's cool that basically we could
take apart which is very idiomatic and
node and done everywhere but handle it
in in a really nice concise new way this
could also be used in JSX was actually
one of the motivating examples I don't
know how many of you have tried to in
JSX do any type of conditionals but you
have to do you have to return something
and usually you do a condition and and
the value that you want to return and if
you want to do turn Aries then you have
to do the condition question mark and do
a few of them if you have multiple cases
there's no nice way to do that you have
to do the nested turn Aries so here what
it would look like is that we could have
a component and let's say that the
component inside of its props could
either be in a loading state or it could
have some errors or it could have none
of those and then it just gives you the
data back so instead what we would do is
we would just do a case over the props
and we would tell it how to handle each
of those and what to return in each of
those cases I encourage you to write the
same example in JSX
and then see what you think about this
proposal afterwards cuz this this is
super nice so having talked about all of
that let's talk about where pattern
matching is because like I mentioned
it's not reality right now so right now
it's a proposal in stage one of tc39 so
stage one is that it's been evaluated
it's been talked about and it's
interesting enough that tc39 is
interested in pursuing pursuing it more
and figuring out what it would take to
make this a part of the language so this
means that the semantics are being
discussed a lot more all of the edge
cases are trying to be identified so
that we can define how would this fit
into the language what's really cool I
didn't know a lot about this until
researching this talk tc39 is a github
organization and basically all of the
documents that go into the language that
all of us use are just documents on
github so the the repository for pattern
matching is right now just some readme
files that you can go through you can in
your head kind of say oh what what would
it mean in this case
what would it mean in this other case
you can open up issues saying I'm not
sure it would work the way that I would
expect it in here what does that mean so
this means that right now contributing
to the proposal is really easy it's all
just thought experiments the next step
after this would be to figure out how to
actually play around with it and how to
get it in the wild so right now let's
skip to the bottom there's this library
called sweet j/s which enables you to do
macros so basically to extend the
JavaScript language however you want I
generally don't think the macros are a
good idea but they're fun and they
enable you to play out with things like
that before with this before they're
ready so sweet J's right now has a macro
that enables you to do this style of
pattern matching it's actually where a
lot of the inspiration for this proposal
comes from there's also in the works a
babel plugin that is going to enable you
to use this syntax and try it out so if
this all sounds interesting there's a
couple different things you can do one
is you could go to TC 39 and follow the
pattern matching repo then whenever
anything happens there you'll be
notified of it too is that you can find
the pull request for the babel plugin
and then follow that I can tweet out a
link to that so that if that's what
you're interested in you can just follow
that pull request and see what's
happening there and the last option
would be I'm doing another talk about
this in Argentina in October so if you
just follow me this is my Twitter handle
I'll be tweeting out a lot more about it
and I can be sure that you get all the
information about pattern matching that
you could want so if that sounds
interesting I have my blog that I put
some stuff up on the company that I work
for testable also has a ton of great
articles on our blog I encourage you to
go look at both of them here's a picture
of me and my sister during the World Cup
wearing our Colombia jerseys because
we're very patriotic and like I
mentioned earlier I work for a
consulting company called testable what
we do is we go into other companies that
already have their established
development teams and we're all
experienced engineers that can fit into
the team and help you work on whatever
it is you're trying to work on at the
time our goal from doing that is to of
course help you deliver whatever it is
you're trying to deliver but also to do
some coaching on how
do remote work we're a fully remote
company so we help companies that are
trying to make a transition over to
doing that we help companies with agile
practices and with testing practices to
help them better deliver code in the
future and like I said we try to just be
really nice with everyone we interact
with so if that sounds like people you'd
like to work with you can go ahead and
go to test double slash contact to ask
us what that would look like for your
company or if that sounds like some
place you'd like to work at I'd love to
have you as my coworker so you can go to
test double comm /join thank you all
very much for joining I hope you have a
great time at the rest of this
conference and come say hi to me if you
see me around Thanks
[Applause]